hey guys it's dr. Burke here I want to
explain what is behind cracked lips and
sometimes you see people with like
really dry crack lips that is a
deficiency of vitamin b2 and vitamin b3
now here's the thing what would create a
deficiency of b2 and b3 well you got
several things one definitely alcohol
will do it alcoholics always are
deficient in these two but typically
what I find it's too much refined flour
products now if you notice when you buy
flour products like bread it's always
enriched with B vitamins right why is
that because refined wheat products
deplete you of those B vitamins so they
put them back in because they're empty
and if you if you consume them actually
deplete you of those B vitamins you'll
end up with the B vitamin deficiency if
you consume a lot of flour products and
that would be in the bread the pasta
cereal the crackers are this gets the
waffles things like that which I know
you never eat but probably you know
people will do now there's other reasons
why you can have crack lips as well you
know you could be zinc deficient you can
be vitamin A deficient okay but this is
the it's usually too many wheat products
now what foods have b2 and b3 one of the
best foods that I like is egg yolks yeah
the to the the things that people think
that are going to increase your
cholesterol which is absolutely
positively true because it will increase
your good cholesterol it will not
increase your bad cholesterol okay
so that's the point and by the way you
may have already known this but your
body makes cholesterol it makes a lot it
makes 3,000 milligrams a day yeah your
liver makes 2,000 and your rest your
body make a thousand that's 3000
milligrams of cholesterol that's
equivalent to 14 eggs that's equivalent
to three hundred strips of bacon that's
equivalent of a pound of butter so the
point is that if you
makes that much adding some egg yolks is
not going to be a big deal because your
body will just make less okay because
you need cholesterol but that's a whole
other video but egg yolks have the B
vitamins they have the vitamin A they
have the zinc so that's what I would
recommend I personally do at least three
eggs a day okay I think that's it's a
really good multivitamin mineral but
make sure you Ang's are pasture-raised
not pasteurized pasture-raised organic
now here's the other thing that's
interesting is allow the animal products
that you buy our fed grains that are GMO
genetically modified that pesticides and
things like that and those grains tend
to affect the nutrition in the animal as
well so if you're doing like
pasture-raised eggs versus just regular
eggs or you're doing
I don't know grass-fed beef versus
regular grain-fed you're getting a much
better quality nutrient profile alright
but if you want to fix your crack lip
lips just go ahead and have the egg
yolks and you'll see that within like a
week or so that symptom will go away
hope you like this and I'll see in the
next video